[拍手]
皆さんはじめまして私は書道家の舞樹と申します
俺がきました
2つありがとうございます見た目で私とっても元気なんですけれども実はまだ難病指定
をされていない戦域痛症という病気を抱えています
この病気を聞きなれない方も多くいらっしゃると思うんですけれどもどういった病気か
と申しますと
製品通称こういった文字を書きましてストレスに対して脳が過敏になり興奮することに
よって痛みに対してハビンになる病気です
このいった実はストレスが角個人でことがありまして
ストレスに何とストレスについて百科事典があるぐらい
ストレスには様々なよそガスを含まれています
して
この製品2勝というのは24時間痛みが変わることはありません
痛みの箇所をどんどん移動していきます
不思議な病気ですよね本当に厄介です
まず私が発症したときの話をしようと思います
発症しましたのは2010年の7月です
突然左足の太もも
すごい激痛が走りました
この激痛が起こったことはいまだに忘れることができませ
同年9月に私は確定診断を受けて晴れてと言ってもいいんでしょうか
病名がわからないすごく不安な時期を抜けて線維筋痛症患者になりました
普段できていた道上生活のことがどんどんできなくなっていきます
まず1つ目
力を入れると痛くなってペットボトルを開けることができません
またフラ伸びてるシャワー
水圧が痛くてゆるくしないといざ印です
また服を違えるとき
痛いです
もう痛みのあまりに中生活でできることはどんどんなくなっていきます
そして私は歩くことすらままなままならない状況になっていきます
そんな私のその時期の人生をはっきり言って
平成の最大の絶望機といっても過言ではありません
この真っ黒の絶望私は真っ白な光で打ち破ることができました
どうしてそれが出来るとか出来てしまったのかというのを超皆さんに伝えたい点は
jal
指定を変えるこのことを皆さんに考え方をシェアできればと思っています
を変えるということは様々な解釈があります
まず一つ目に健康と2つ目に仕事をの観点についてお話をさせていただこうと思います
皆さん健康ですか
元気ですか元気な人てあげてください今日元気だよ
いいですねぇ私病気なのでてあげられません痛いです
ちなみに今日痛いのはへ右手のですね二の腕のあたり長や世帯あたりが痛いです
困ったもんです次どこが痛くなるか分からないのでちょっと予想も
つかないんですけれど非常に強い状況です
そんな私は病気をすることによって傾向の人と同じように働くことができなくなって
しまいました
病気を発症する前私は書道の仕事ではなくて会社で事務の仕事をしていました
ですが通勤時間1時間あったんですけれども
1時間立ったままができないんですまず通うことができなくなりました
座ったとしても痛みがすごくて正直途中で倒れてしまってあので者の中で急病人の介護
おために送れますでは治すを聞いた方いらっしゃると思うんですけれどもまさにその
状態を何回を起こしてしまいました
そして私はどんどんできなくなってしまうことをすごく不安になり
どうしよう何も出来ない何もできないどんどん落ち込んでいきます
ですがこの時視点を変えるという考え方で私は救われていきます
同じ健康の人とつ
病気仕事しなくていい病気の私でもできる仕事があるんじゃないかと言う
考え方にチェンジしていきます
まず2ピン時間がなくて0者にもまれなくてもよくていろんなことをすごく単純に考え
ていたんですけれども
曲残ったのは6歳から続けていた
書道の仕事です
病気をきっかけに私は書道の道を本格的に志すことを決意しました
これが私の別作品の一つなんですけれども
用地になった当初はもちろん体が痛いので
大きなパフォーマンスをすることができませんでした
ですがハガキサイズの小さい紙に気持ちを込めて
一文字でも書くことによって私はカブ倒しさを追い出しました
そしてできることが一つ増えたアコの達成かのじゃうことにもう絶望から抜け出す一つ
を
大きな一歩になったと言えるでしょう
私は6歳から書道を始め17歳で毛質の市販の明記を取得しました
大学時代はクレージ angel company といって
社会人主に社会人の方が全員の妲己を拭いて善意が時にはカラーガードで旗を振って
踊ってダンスをして時にや芝居もするというスタイルの舞台を続けていましたその中で
こういったいっしょ起きる
和風ろくなが方雅に吠えるといったステージがあって
ああああああ
私をしてなサックスやカラーガードだけではなくて
ちょうど経験者ということでしょとパフォーマンスもしていました
俺です別なあのちなみに私
こっちですわかりにくいと思うんですけど
そのことがきっかけでロボを書かせていただいたりパフォーマンスをしていくうちに
事務職の傍ら人づてに小さいながらもいろいろな筆文字を書くお仕事を頂戴することが
できました
そのことをふっと私は思い出しずきん時間入らないじゃないか
家で出来るでしょそう思って
30なんですけれどもそういった経緯もありまして所蔵母の道を志しました
志たで今行っているのは書道家の道がまだ
終わらないからでしょ度はに終わりはありません人生ずっと鍵て私は筆を持って字を
書いていくと思います
病気の時を何回も思いました私にはパク事しかのかされていない
はいた文字の皆さんはすごく喜んで下さることが私は自分自身を肯定することに繋がっ
て非常にうれしかったことを今でも鮮明に覚えています
実際ば品
元気になってからはこういった大きいパフォーマンスをすることまだ出来るまでに
今は回復しています
開封するとしてるのですが投薬治療を続け今は製品通称と同居している
共存ですねもう一人田舎仲間がいる感じ
そんな感じで病気と仲良く生きていこうと思っています
次は仕事のことについて再度触れたいと思うんですけれども
この所蔵の仕事
自分を肯定することですごく楽になったと今言ったんですけれども
やっぱり人に褒められることって嬉しいんですよね
それが私の回復になったきっかけの1つでもあります
ちょっと話を進めていきます
そうでしょ
このマー君ご存知の方いらっしゃいますか見たことあるよってだけでもいいんですけど
てあげてくださいありがとうございます
結構多くの方がいらっしゃいますねこのマークはヘルプマークと言います
援助などを必要とされている方例えば義足であったり
私のように見えない障害を抱えている人々が外見のわからない障害ですね
周囲の方々に助けを求めていることを
ん
知らせて援助を受けやすくするために作成されたマークです
失礼しました東京都の都への地下鉄で無料で配布されていただくことができます
てる部マーク2
ましてはあの席を譲ってほしいからこの話をしているわけではありません
あくまで伝えたいことは視点を変えることです皆さん電車の中で何してますかあの
スマホをいじってるよって人
多いですね
読書してるよを読んでるよ新聞読んであぁ
を多くいらっしゃいます
寝てるっていう方いらっしゃいますか
んいいですね電車の中って心地よい眠りがあっていいですよね
そんな様々な報道を座りながらされると思うんですけれども
やっていること電車の中でやっていることから少し顔の角度を上げてみてください
そしたら
目の前にマタニティーマークやっぽいたヘルプマークそして杖をついている方が
いらっしゃる可能性があります
そういった方々にやはりある席を譲ってほしいということではないんですけれども
もし自分がそういった立場の方々だったら
な技をしてほしいかそういったイマジネーションを働かせてもらいたい
と思っていますそれも指定を変えることの一つだと解釈しております
ここ目立つんですよねこれねっ
をつけるのが難しいので改善をして欲しいなぁと思っているんですけれども
してこのマークができたと同時に私が早速もらったんですけれども電車の中です譲って
いただけることはほとんどありませんでした
大体あのマークを見たかと譲ってくださる方ももちろんいるんですけれども
スマホをいじる寝たふりを始める
この2つが読書するをいきなり突然見た後に始めるという方もいらっしゃって少し残念
なんですけれども
やはり
相手の立場になってっていうことをすごく重要なことだと私は思っていますそのことを
視点を変えると今回呼ばせていただいております
このことはすぐできますたった15秒でもいいと思います
今日帰宅中にぜひよかったら電車の中で
15秒自分の身の回りにいる家族や友達
どういった言葉やどういった行動したら相手は
いい気持ちになるかなとか
相手はうざ
お店
をしてあげたら月最近元気ないけど
ちょっと元気出してくれるかなという時間にあててみてください
そしてその出たアイデアをぜひ実行してください
そのことで皆さん自身や周りの方々の人生を非常に豊かになっていくと思いますこれは
間違いないでしょ
なぜなら私たちは他人の存在無くして人生を実り多いものにすることができないから
です
一人で人生を歩んだのほとんど何もできないと思いますよ
周りの方々家族や友人そしてが職場や学校の人いろんな方がいるから私たちの人生が
形成されていますそして他人カラー耐えられと選択集を日々先着しながら
今日もその会場に来るという選択をしてこの場にいらっしゃると思います
それも他人がいるから
そのことを一つ胸に留めてほしいなと思っています
さて最後の話をしたいと思います
私たちの人生において視点を変えるということは非常に有効なことだと考えています
それはなぜならば相手の立場に立って
考えるということは自分自身のアイディアのストップができることが一つ
そして最初話した通り
真っ黒な絶望から
真っ白い光として絶望打ち砕くことができるからです
私がなぜうちぐだぐ真っ黒の絶望から真っ白んぬ
光です絶望を口破ることができたかというと
ついにいろいろな言葉を掛けてもらったからという経緯があります
わけのわからない病気だと思いは知らない方よって私ももちろん性筋痛症知らなかった
ので
なんじゃこりゃと思って慌てて性筋痛症患者さんのブログを隅から隅まで隅から隅まで
読みました
すごく参考になりました
そこで得たしてる気づきもありますし家族や友人からもらった言葉
その言葉たちのおかげで今の私がいると思っていますそして病気を機に私は書道の道を
志しましたのでもしこの病気というきっかけがなければ
書道家の前時はこのように存在しなかっ
たと言えます本当に存在しなかったと思ってます真剣に病気に感謝しているわけでは
ありませんがみなさんも何かトラブルが起こったときに少し
してを変えるチェンジ
してみてください
色々な事実があると思いますが会社か無限大です
今日皆様に覚えていただきたいというのは僭越な言葉でございますが心に留めておいて
ほしいということは視点を変えるということ相手の立場に立って自分自身
相手にとって実り豊かな
人生を歩めるんじゃないかという提案をさせていただきました
私のスピーチはここまでになりますがこんなとぽつらで書道パフォーマンスを行います
是非ご覧ください
書いた文字は悪文字ですね
たった一つの c ワード
キーワードという事実ですですがそれを今日の話とともにどう受け取るかは皆さんの
考え次第で間違った魂考えや気持ちは一切ありません
是非はいた文字と今話した視点を変えるというポイントについて
ミックスして
今日の時間を有意義に過ごしていただければ幸いでございます
本日は誠にご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]